exactly i'll say this the mega movement
is going to mobilize
the mega movement is going to mobilize
turn against the gop and you're going to
see all kinds of crazy stuff that they
never thought were going to happen
you know what you know if trump loses
this election maybe this will
finally be when we break the two-party
system
you know or whatever i am a little bit
excited about this because i think
that's gonna happen i think you're right
drew
i think the maga movement is gonna
separate from the republican movement i
think that's gonna happen
i don't see any other way because i
don't see the maga people as being
really super republicans in that they
would be willing to sit on their hands
if they
saw something this happened i see i see
all these people tweeting where where is
the gop leadership to come
back on this and to like exactly they're
not they're nowhere they won't have us
back no no of course
this is what they always do the gop this
is why i criticize them all the time and
like i get criticized by antifa and all
these radical leftists oh you're
you're a heavy right winger republican
i'm like dude i have major issues with
the republican party because of stuff
like this
whenever the republican party has the
opportunity to go on
some serious offense they just sit on
their hands and do nothing
and i think people are sick of this when
have you ever seen a turtle
go on the offensive uh when mitch
mcconnell
am i not no first of all in the master
of disguise he bites that guy's nose
that's true that's true
enough for the turtle
mitch mcconnell yep is sitting back and
he's what he he's he's he's comfortable
and he's not going to stick his neck out
probably and that's a problem that's a
problem that guy really needs to come
out of his shell
i agree no i would be i would be
interested to see if like there was like
a maga party
20 20 you know 2022 we see midterms then
also we get weird third party
uh nominees actually start winning
that'd be cool because i mean think
about it trump has
the yeah trump got more more votes the
republican party got more votes in this
election than in history yeah that's
true joe biden is saying he got more
votes
you know than any other president in
history also while technically the truth
it is actually uh more fair i believe uh
in the literal sense to say trump got
more anti-trump votes than any other
president
yeah for sure but his hispanic vote the
hispanic vote
for texas
so here's what i'm thinking look you got
68 million people right now yeah like
i i don't like the republicans i don't
like the republicans or the democrats
so in 2022 i'm looking for alternatives
yeah i'd vote for a third i'm definitely
gonna vote for third party probably next
time
i mean we'll see unless you know so even
aoc admitted
that the democrat party is kind of
losing
voter base with latinos yep right so i
think
i think that's something that is going
to be really mobilized and utilized
see but this is the gop just i don't
understand it's like
you have the potential to really tap
into these
voter bases but you guys don't well
trump
my point is trump has done things that
they were willing to never do he
accomplished them
and now they're just completely
neglecting it and this is what makes me
think that
the moop the base is going to move this
is what makes me think that
is going to move away but hold on a
second i i think democrats might as well
that's possible how many people like how
many people right now are voting against
trump and they're
unhappy with joe biden like what what
was that sign in dc
we don't want joe biden we want revenge
yeah he's five percent
five or six people i would say as high
as seven i think
i don't know right right now according
to gallup 40 or so percent of the
democratic party
views themselves as progressives which
is at least at least
five or six people right yes yes that's
correct yeah we'll take it no i think i
think it's entirely possible
you've got democrats right now i'm
seeing it from on my feed from
progressives they're saying
that the democrats it's their fault for
putting forth
unlikable candidates yeah these
pandering you know centrist
corporate types that appeal to no one
trying to appeal to everyone
and they should have chosen progressive
maybe yeah i mean a progressive wouldn't
appeal to everyone no it doesn't matter
though because joe biden didn't get
votes
yeah they could have they could have put
up a ham sandwich
and and the trump arrangement syndrome
people would go vote for it yeah that's
true
so how does joe biden get more
popular vote than barack obama
that's what i want how is joe biden more
popular than barack obama right now i
don't know he's not
he's not someone needs to answer trump
is i know well really i don't know i
think that
but i'm asking how did that wrong i
think that joe biden actually drove the
obama administration i think that people
actually like joe biden obama wasn't
voting for obama yeah yeah i don't think
obama was very charismatic at all i
think that
obama had all of these weird guys i'm
going to disagree with you on this
one but joe everyone knew that no biden
was the cool guy and that's what i don't
know
you know how you do it on obama
impersonation you go uh
here's the deal what may be perfectly
clear
and everyone's like enough of this guy i
want i want an old smooth joe i want no
malarkey
that's who has mine and and and biden is
so
smooth he puts all his words it's
streamlined he puts all the words into
one word
so that you know i don't want to listen
to life could you imagine
having having to listen to five words
of pressure he made that one one word i
have no idea what he was saying but it
was one word that's impressive
this is the crazy thing like he's like
literally a soundcloud rapper he totally
is
yeah like that's it joe biden like
that's what they do
should i write a rap song called true
i have a question for you guys so do you
guys remember during the kavanaugh thing
no no no no okay well i'm gonna i'm
about to refresh your memory sons listen
up okay
so during the kavanagh thing i was very
impressed by lindsey graham
do you remember what lindsey graham was
saying no he was saying things like
y'all want pr you all want power and i
hope you never get it yes
he was saying things like uh heaven help
me if you guys had done to me what
you've done to this man you're trying to
ruin his life i will not
stand for it where is that lindsay why
don't i have him back
he's there like he exists he's a real
thing he's a real person mitch mcconnell
is savage like he knows what he's doing
democrats
are cut throat brutal
psycho rule changers you've got people
marching the streets screaming you had a
woman
in in in new york spray children
children but that's because they were
sitting in a car with a trump flag
yeah but that's just normal behavior tim
these people listen
you never pepper spray children when you
see them with a flag that you don't want
wow that's a good point that's a normal
person thing that normal people do
i am excited for the future
because you know what at least life's
not boring that's true
i'm half kidding by the way actually i
have kidding here's the thing
there's this question of how
conservatives are going to handle this
and drew you made a good point earlier
about the fact that we can sort of take
the l here and be mature and if we did
lose we can acknowledge that we lost
and one thing that i can promise is if
joe biden wins
i am not going to cut out a single
family member or friend or loved one who
voted for him yeah i think they made a
horrible choice
i think that if joe biden wins millions
more of more unborn children are going
to die i think tens of thousands of more
people in the middle east are going to
die
this will be a price paid in human blood
and i take that very seriously but what
i take more seriously than that
is my own development as a person and my
soul and my virtue and those are the
things that you have control over you
don't have control over who's the
president after you cast your vote
and i hope that conservatives can keep
that in mind and not react the same
without the left
and i'm pretty sure that they won't but
that's
great you know what i'm going to do when
joe biden gets in office
i believe he'll very likely reenact the
policies of
his past administration with barack
obama we're going to see a lot of dead
kids in the middle east we're going to
see an expansion of our presence we're
going to see
these peace agreements potentially
falling apart i don't know for sure
maybe they'll hold maybe you know
biden's kind of put in that position
but i'm going to send every news article
to each and every one of my friends who
told me that they were voting for biden
you should
every single day i'm gonna be like here
read it yeah no definitely let them know
you know probably that i know and i
definitely think that these
conversations need to happen with with
people who
voted for joe biden we should still want
to persuade them but you do that by
caring for them by being there for them
by being a genuine friend who has
concern
over them and their lives but wanting
them to improve and sort of calling them
out of their errors here
not by cutting them out not by saying
they're horrible people i think the
issue is
uh tribalism ego and
for whatever reason people just they
want to be a part of that wave
you know when everyone's running around
screaming orange man bad they're like oh
i think the orange man is bad too can i
can i hang out with you guys
i mean being part of a crowd is very
appealing it's extremely appealing
i think i think joe biden is a hollow
shell like i think he's literally a
hollow shell
he he's he's just gonna do whatever he's
told whatever they tell him to do when
black lives matter comes through
i give it four months if joe biden
becomes president the white house will
be painted black in four months
i think you're right i think we're going
to see a lot of things that the sjws and
the radical communists want do he's not
going to be able to stand his ground no
donald trump is definitely doing that
he's not going to be able to tame blm
he's not going to be able to tame antifa
none of these radical organizations
he's going to do what they want that's
literally what they're going to do
i don't know if i agree i think i think
he's going to throw them red meat
and they're going to make gains in weird
and creepy ways
where he won't stand his ground but i
also think that
he's going to make sure he locks the
keys to the castle not him
but the democratic establishment is
going to make sure that these people
like the progressives the right
populists they want it to be crony
establishment
yes military-industrial complex wall
street it's going to go back to the days
of obama well and
he's going to he's going to fill his
cabinet with goldman sachs citibank
never trumpers so depressed exactly see
and then i think riots
are going to continue yeah that goes
perfectly to my point
right because people voted for biden
thinking that the riots are going to go
away they think that trump is
a centralized issue wrong you already
correct fake news
i completely agree i mean if there's one
thing come on if there's one thing the
past 10
20 years even the history of the 20th
century should tell you it's that giving
the left
small victories does not make them go
away it makes them hungry for more
and so if we vote for joe biden because
we're afraid that the rights won't stop
unless we do well guess what they're
just going to be even more out of
control because we gave them what they
wanted
and when you reward behavior you get
more spoiling a kid yeah
exactly than they are children they
definitely are for sure
very very addressed violence at nine pm
we are getting another
batch of ballots from arizona so uh
it'll be coming at some point i don't
know exactly if it will be at eight i'm
not entirely sure
but as of right now uh well
it looks like there's still votes coming
in from arizona
and it seems like donald trump is
actually working down uh
joe biden's lead oh my wow 88 reporting
i mean joe biden uh joe biden might lose
this one i'm
i'm seeing 90 reporting in arizona and
there's what side are you on i'm sorry
i'm on uh i'm on
the google home page but it's associated
press i believe it's from the associated
press
that's probably a better source i'm sure
the new york times yeah it's from the
associated press
anything's a better source than new york
times donald trump donald trump's lead
is down to 50
000 votes in pennsylvania oh my gosh 94
percent
it's only 90 reports
if trump wins by like one or two votes
yeah it will be the
last thing that's so cool because we're
gonna be like whoa no you know what that
would be that would be hilarious
you want to know why because the left
right now is losing their minds
they're saying that donald trump is
filing lawsuits
in order to steal the election and if
that were to happen tim
they're going to be the ones to file
lawsuits
and they're going to be the conspiracy
theorists they'll be the fascists
they'll be the scary nazis and it's
going to be hilarious to see that
because
this is what they do lydia i know this
is what these people do they accuse you
of what they are and what they want to
do they project because they're morons
they project because they're liars and
they want to convince us that we're the
fascists
and that we're the ones that are the bad
ones bro one million percent 100 million
percent
here's here's something crazy some of
the most important elections are the
ones where weird
reporting issues are happening right
yeah so jeff van drew
is up a a decent amount how's he doing
um around
12 000 or so votes oh he's gonna win no
76 reporting and it's slowly going in
amy kennedy's favorite
interesting the other really interesting
thing that we saw was in
uh pa district 17. yeah which is
it was for sean parnell he was winning
by
like a decent margin and then uh so they
issued a statement
all of a sudden some mail-in bouts came
in all for conor lamb oh how weird
and then conor lamb immediately declares
victory oh and so sean parnell's
campaign said something like
he was saying we shouldn't call it until
all the votes are in
then as soon as he takes a small lead he
says no we're gonna call it you know
we're calling
and so sean parnell is like no we're
gonna wait for every every vote to come
in it's 92 percent
so there have been there have been weird
instances where
uh mail-in boxes come in and it's like
100 democrat it's not weird yeah
and they say they say well that's
because trump was discouraging people
no no no no 100 yeah like even 90
no no no 70 okay maybe yeah but
but i'm not i'm not buying it man thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time